We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
I got a voicemail early this morning.
I actually don't know what this person is
talking about.
I just.
I think they're mad at me.
It's not clear for what?
See if you can help me figure it out.
You're a frickin force.
The only station is Fox News.
You had NBC, ABC.
The frickin newspaper.
And you want to say the orientation there
for you, for or against your pockets or the
frickin day and how you live with yourself?
I really don't know what this person is talking
about.
I don't I'm trying to think of what I said.
I don't know that I've ever said FOX News
is the only anything.
It's not the only pro Trump media outlet.
It's certainly not a liberal media outlet.
It's not.
I mean, I just have no idea what this person
is talking about.
If somebody has a better recollection from
from last week's shows and you maybe can tell
me what it is this person is talking about,
please let me know because I have no clue
what it is.
OK, we have a very important bonus show today.
Everyday we do an additional show.
So there's the show that is ending soon.
And then there's the next bonus show, which
is every single day for our paid subscribers.
OK, we are going to talk about qualified immunity
for police accused of misconduct.
This is a really important apparatus that,
were it removed or limited, would make it
easier to go after police when they behave
badly.
The Supreme Court is weighing qualified immunity.
We're going to talk about it on today's bonus
show.
Number two, FOX News put up this crazy graphic,
essentially showing how well the stock market
sometimes does when there are tragic incidents
like black people being killed by police or
riots or different things.
We are now going to tell you not only what
the graph said, but FOX News has apologized.
And, hey, you know what?
Trump never apologizes.
At least Fox News is apologizing.
That's something we can say.
And then lastly, the editor of The New York
Times has resigned after backlash over an
editorial written and published written by
Republican Senator John Cotton, Tom Cotton
and published by The New York Times.
Blowback has now led to the editor, James
Bennet, resigning.
Is this the right thing?
We are going to talk about all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
join Pacman dot com.
And remember to get the daily free podcast
on iTunes, Google Play, Spotify, Pandora,
Stitcher or whatever podcasting program or
app you prefer.
The Daily Audio Podcast.
A very popular way of consuming the show for
many of our viewers.
I encourage you to check it out.
We'll see you on the bonus.